THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON AG WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON AS
WE COULD YOU TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RANKS SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
BY THE- TO BOTH IN SENATE TELL
US FOR DISSIPATION COMIC BRENDA
THE- PROVIDE FULL. VIA THE TO
CONFERENCE SERVICE THE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE- PO ON
OUR COMMITTEE. AND NOW I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. STAYS
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS CODE
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT. NINE ZERO
THREE NOT. I WILL MEAN THE
DURING THIS HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY- IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
BY CENTER GLAZER FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. THAT WOULD
REQUIRE APOLOGIZE. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE. WAS TRICKY BUILDING. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
BEGAN OUR HEARING. AT THE MOMENT
WE ARE AWAITING SOME FOLKS. AND
FOR. THE LITTLE ALL RIGHT ARE WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA THREE OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT I. LET PUBLISHED THAT
QUORUM KENTUCKY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BORJAS PRESENT FOR JUST
PRESENT HER TADO CABALLERO
CAREER PRESENT EGGMAN GLAZER
PRESENT GLAZER PRESENT ALL
RIGHTS NOTING A QUORUM HAS BEEN%
ESTABLISHED FOR SURE BUSINESSES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR BILL OF.
BILLS CONSENT OR FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO AND FOUR RESPECTIVELY SB
NINE OH SEVEN TEN TWENTY NINE
AND FOURTEEN NINETY NINE- THE WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BY CENTER GLAZER- ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- CONSISTING
THE ITEMS ONE TWO AND FOUR.
HELLO CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SURE GORGEOUS HIGH FOR JUST
HI HURTADO CABALLERO. CAREER
HIGH EGGMAN GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE ALRIGHT WE'LL KEEP THAT ON
CALM AS WE AWAIT MORE MEMBERS-
ALL RIGHT WE'RE JUST GONNA WAIT
FOR CENTER TADO SHE'S ARE ONLY
ITEM OF BUSINESS AND SO WE WILL
SUSPEND FOR AN APARTMENT.
LET THE RECORD REFLECT THAT
CENTER HER TADO HAS ARRIVED TO
GREAT FANFARE CENTER HER TADO-
WOULD YOU PLEASE PRESENT YOUR
BILL SB. TEN EIGHT FOUR. I WOULD
LOVE TO THANK YOU RATE CHAIR. SO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY A
SEVENTEEN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS I ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THESE AMEND.
AS THE GLOBAL EVENTS HAVE SHOWN
HOW INTERCONNECTED WE ARE AND
HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE IMPORTANCE
OF UNDERSTANDING EXACTLY. WAS IN
CONTROL OF THE RESOURCES WE
DEPEND ON INCLUDING OUR OWN. THE. INCLUDING GLOBAL PHYSICAL
SECURITY AS WELL AS FOOD
SECURITY. THERE ARE LOOMING
CONCERNS THAT THE CONFLICT IN
UKRAINE COULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE FOOD INSECURITY
PARTICULARLY FOR NATIONS IN NEED
. BETWEEN THEM UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA PRODUCED 30% OF THE
WORLD'S WITH SUPPLY 20% OF ITS
CORN SUPPLY AND SEVENTY FIVE. UP
280% OF THE WORLD'S SUNFLOWER
SEED OIL. THE WORLD FOOD PROGRAM
BUYS 50% OF ITS GRAIN FROM
UKRAINE. CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY PRODUCES
ONE THIRD OF OUR COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES ANDTWO THIRDS OF OUR
COUNTRY'S FRUITS AND NUTS AND
ALSO PROVIDES FOOD TO THOSE IN
NEED ALL OVER THE WORLD. ON
AVERAGE 40% OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL OUTPUT IS EXPORTED
GLOBALLY. THE AGRICULTURAL LAND
TO PRODUCE THESE CROPS IS
INVALUABLE TO OUR STATE GDP. AS
WELL AS TO FEEDING THE STATE IN
THE NATION. AND THE PAST FEW
YEARS. FOREIGN OWNERSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL LAND
TESTED LEE INCREASED. BETWEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY
FOREIGN OWNERS PURCHASED OVER
FORTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND IN CALIFORNIA
. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SPECIFICALLY. A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
HAVE. A OF AGRICULTURAL LAND IS
HELD IN FOREIGN OWNERSHIP. THE
LAND PURCHASES BUT CALIFORNIA'S
POTENTIALLY CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SECURITY AT RISK EXTENDING NOT
ONLY TO DOMESTIC YOUTH BUT ALSO
TO OUR EXPORTS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL EXPORTS WERE
MEASURED AT TWENTY ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION IN VALUE. SB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR PREVENTS FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS FROM PURCHASING
AGRICULTURAL LAND IN CALIFORNIA
. ADDITIONALLY SB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO COMPILE
AN ANNUAL REPORT HIGHLIGHTING
VARIOUS TRENDS RELATING TO
FOREIGN OWNERSHIP ON
AGRICULTURAL LAND. RIGHT THIRTY
FACILITIES ENERGY FACILITIES.
THIS WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA HAS
UP TO DATE INFORMATION O TRENDS
ON FOREIGN OWNERSHIP OF MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S IMPORTANT RESOURCES
. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THE
NUMEROUS OTHER STATES HAVE LAWS
WITH VARIOUS LEVELS OF
RESTRICTIONS AND PROHIBITIONS
AROUND. ALL FOREIGN OWNERSHIP OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND. IOWA FOR
EXAMPLE PROHIBITS FOREIGN
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENTS FROM OWNING
AGRICULTURAL LAND. MISSISSIPPI
PROHIBITS FOREIGN NON RESIDENTS
FROM ALL OWNERSHIP OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND. WHY LIMITS
SHOULD TO THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN A
RESIDENT OF THE STATE FOR AT
LEAST THREE YEARS. MINNESOTA
LIMITS OWNERSHIP OF AGRICULTURAL
LAND TO CITIZENS AND PERMANENT
RESIDENTS WITH LIMITS PLACED ON
THE LAND OWNED BY PERMANENT
RESIDENTS. THE LAWS AND IN THE
STATE'S SHOW CALIFORNIA WOULD BY
NO MEANS BE THE FIRST STATE TO
ENACT THIS TYPE OF RESTRICTION
ON FOREIGN OWNERSHIP OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND. ACTUALLY BUT
OF DISCUSSION- GIVEN THIS IS A
CONCERN THAT IS GROWING ACROSS
THE NATION. ARE THAT- THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE MORE MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE ONLY STATES THAT
ACTUALLY HAS. JYJ AGRICULTURE
OUTPUT THAT DOES NOT HAVE ANY
KIND OF. LOVE THE SPORT. SO SB
TEN EIGHTY FOUR TOOK THE CRUCIAL
STEPS IT TAKES A CRUCIAL STEP
TOWARDS PROTECTING OUR FOOD
SECURITY BY CREATING A
RESTRICTION ON OWNERSHIP OF
AGRICULTURAL LAND REFORM
GOVERNMENT SPECIFICALLY. AND
TODAY AB ONE WITNESS JOIN US
REMOTELY. JOHN WEREN'T OF OWN
OWNER OF WARNER FARMS. THANK
THANK YOU GENERAL. PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. SORRY THANK YOU
SENATOR CONFERENCE RIGHT ME TO
SPEAK TODAY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME- AS I
PROVIDE YOU SOME LOCAL
CONTRACTOR OR PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS- I PERSONALLY FEEL SEVEN
ACRES IN THE LAKE COUNTY REGION
OF OCALA YEAH WE WERE ALL OF.
FIGS ON OUR- I'M A SMALL FARMER
MIGHT FORCE MY THREE KIDS AND MY
WIFE- THE WIFE IS BOSS AND ORDER
TO MAKE ENDS MEET I AM ALSO-
WORKED A JOB IN NUMBER. OUR
LOCAL ACT MEATY- AND UNDERSTAND.
THE LOCAL CONTEXT- WE HAVEN'T
SEEN AN AD YOU DON'T BUY THE
LAND TO FIGHT WATER. AND WHEN
OWNERSHIP OF IT. PERSECUTE BE
ABSOLUTELY. ESTERS INCLUDING GOV
TO INVESTORS IN LAND GAME CAN
AND ACCESS BUY AN ALREADY
LIMITED WATER SUPPLY. UNDER THE
LARGER THE AGRICULTURE. HE IS
THE GREATER ADVANTAGE HAS WITH
REGARDS TO IMPORT AND USE
BALANCES IN OUR GROUND STATE
ABILITY ACT. AS THOSE WELL
FUNDED IN. CAN DEVELOP PHYSICAL
. TO BOTH TOP AND MOVE Y. FROM
REGION TO REGION FURTHERMORE
THEY CAN DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT THE WATER USED ANY
SPECIFIC WHAT. BOB ARE ABLE TO.
WHAT LAND WHERE MY A GAIN
GREATER TO NAY WATER
UNDERSTATEMENT OR RULE SMALL
FARMERS SIMPLY CAN'T COMPETE
WITH THE POWER FOR INVESTORS-
AND FOR THAT SCARCE RESOURCE OF
WATER- THIS IS A WATER OUT AND
CARE. INSURANCE FOR SMALL
BREWERS LIKE MYSELF ARTICLE.
KING ISSUES CONTINUE TO BE A
CONCERN FOR ACT PRODUCT
EXPLOITATION FOREIGN OWNED
AGRIBUSINESSES AND LANDOWNERS
BENEFIT BY BEING ABLE TO SKIRT
FOREIGN COUNTRY IMPORT
RESTRICTIONS ON U. S. GOODS FOR
EXAMPLE WOULD CALIFORNIA GROWERS
STRUGGLES. OF THAT COUNTRY CAN
MORE WE IMPORT THEIR CALIFORNIA
GROWN PRODUCE INTO THEIR OWN
COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY MAKE THE
RULES THERE AND WHILE THIS IS A
GLOBAL ISSUE AFFECT THE
VIABILITY OF LOCAL FARMERS
DURING. IN THE MARKET FOR.
CHANGE YEARS. THIRD POINT THAT I
WANT BRING UP WITH YOU TO. YEAH
I HAVE TO WITH BURKE YOUR- OF
VERTICAL INTEGRATION A CONCERN
WITH CONTROLLED. ANY FOREIGN
ENTITY. I THINK CHIC BURKE
INTEGRATION CONTROL THE FOOD
SUPPLY FROM THE- COULD PROCESS.
IF THEY CONTROL THE PROCESSING
AND FARMLAND THEY CONTROL EVERY
ASPECT OF THE FOOD. FOR
COMPANIES THAT EXHIBITED
VERTICAL INTEGRATION. OF THE
FOOD SOURCE MARKET EXAMPLES
INCLUDE W. H. GROUP- WHICH DEALS
WITH PORK AND GBS WHICH DEALS
WITH ME TO BY THE WAY I THINK
SENATOR. THE STATE IT WAS TACTIC
- DOES HAVE LIMITED. THEY LISTED
THERE LIMITATION A LITTLE BIT TO
ALLOW- WH GROUP HAD TO TAKE. OF
A US TWENTY AND FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND ACRES OF THEIR
FARMLAND WHICH THEN GET TO THE
MONOPOLY ON THE U. S. PORK
INDUSTRY. TO GIVE AN EXAM. PART
OF ME STATE. APPLE OF WHAT HAVE
WHEN YOU LOOSEN THE RAIN ON THIS
LOSE MORE CONTROL SUPPORT COVER
SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO IN SUCH A
VERTICAL INTEGRATION OF
GOVERNMENT. WITH ONE GRACE AND
IN MIND PURCHASE FOOD
MANUFACTURING FACILITY TO
PROCESSING PLANT IN THE LAND
USED TO PRODUCE THE RAW GOODS IT
WOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH ABSOLUTE
CONTROL OF FOOD PRODUCTS.
GOVERNMENT BY. TO REALLY CONTROL
FOOD PIPELINE OUR FUTURE THIS
CALL X. LET ME THINK MISTER
WARNER COULD COULD YOU PLEASE-
RIGHT IT UP. YES WANTED TO SAY.
THAT IT'S A MATTER OF THREE ARE
YOU CONCERNED OUR WATER
SCARCITY- ACCESS TO GLOBAL
VERTICAL INTEGRATION CONCERN IS-
ONE OF THE GREATEST CONCERNS-
FROM THE FIELD OUT HERE IN.
THANK YOU YOUR- I'M SINCE THAT
INDIVIDUAL MR WARNER WAS YOUR
ONLY A WITNESS LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED ANY INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO COMMENT SEEING NONE
LET'S MOVE TO ONLINE MODERATOR-
DO WE HAVE ANY VISUALS WISHING
TO IN. THE SPILL AIR SO IF YOU
COULD LET ME KNOW HOW MANY ARE
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MOVING-
TO THOSE THAT MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE
ON FILE- THAT I KNOW OF ON. WITH
OPPOSITION ANYONE. SEEING NONE
OF MODERATE CAN YOU GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ANY INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AFTER FIVE. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAYS- I'M GONNA START OFF WITH A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. TO THE
AUTHOR- I LIKE THE IDEA GENERAL
GIST OF. OF WHAT IS. BEING IT
BEING ATTEMPTED HERE IN FACT MY
OFFICE NINE- WE HAD- A BILL THAT
WE WERE WORKING ON- THAT HAD
SOME SIMILARITIES TO THIS- BUT
I'M I WANTED TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THERE WAS CLARITY ON ONE
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR- BECAUSE I
THINK. HE ANALYSIS AND MAYBE
EVEN THE WAY IN PACKAGED- BY
PRESENTATION A WAR BY OTHERS.
IS THAT WERE REFERRING TO IT AS
FOREIGN OWNERSHIP. NOW THE BILL
INDICATES. LET'S SEE WHERE IT IS
ON. THIS WOULD BE THE ONE TO
THREE FOURTH PARAGRAPH THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT. ART AND BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT IS BEING. USED IN A
WAY THAT IS IDENTIFYING IT AS
FOREIGN OWNERSHIP. IS THERE A
DISTINCTION WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT ON THAT ISSUE YES THE
DENTAL OF THE ILL IS GUEST ON
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS. NOW EIGHT
MAKING PART OF THE REASON WHY
FOREIGN OWNERSHIP IS KIND OF
BEING BROUGHT UP IS THAT. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU KNOW OUR
TEAM HAS ALSO BEEN WORKING ON IS
A CORPORATE TRANSPARENCY ACT AT
LEAST WHAT KIND OF WATCHING.
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT WAY IT'S
GOING TO GO. AND PART OF IT IS
THAT THERE'S NOT A WHOLE.
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT ON. UNDERSTANDING
WHERE A CORPORATION. LIKE WHO
THEIR BENEFICIAL OWNERS ARE. AT
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT-
UP THE SHELL CORPORATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU THINK OF THEM LIKE
OPENING UP AND SOME LIKE THE
BAHAMAS OR SOME FOREIGN COUNTRY
RIGHT BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
SHELL CORPORATIONS ARE BEING
FORMED RIGHT HERE IN THE U. S.
AND SO. YOU VERY WELL HAVE A
CORPORATION THAT IS- THE
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION RIGHT AND
IT COULD VERY WELL BE OWNED BY A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT- SO IT SOLD
THE BILL IS FOCUSED ON FOREIGN
GOT ANTS BUT I THINK THAT WITH
THE CORPORATE TRANSPARENCY. ACT
LEGISLATION IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT I THINK
THAT THAT WILL KIND OF BRING TO
LIGHT A LITTLE BIT MORE ASKED TO
WHO IS WAS BEHIND AT THESE BUT
THESE RATIONS YEAH- AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION I DO
WANT TO HONE IN ON THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS. A MYTH ISSUE WILL MOVE
TOWARD- YOU MAY WISH TO I'M NOT
CERTAIN IT'S IN THE FORM OF A
RESPECT TO PRESIDENT. RIGHT
IT'S- IT'S IDENTIFIED AS FOREIGN
. AS ONE ENTERS PRESS. CAN THE
END REPORT THAT IS BEING ASKED
HERE- IS FOR FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
IS IT YOUR INTENTION THAT IT
ALSO INCLUDES. AFFILIATED STATE
OWNED ENTERPRISE. SO I THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS
FOREIGN OWNED GOVERNMENTS. OUR
END SO IT'S WITH RICKY ISSUE I
UNDERSTAND RIGHT SO WHAT IT
HONAN IT'S A SEPARATE IT'S A
SEPARATE ISSUE RIGHT THAT HAS TO
DO FALL. IT'S NOT PART OF THIS
BILL BUT THE CORPORATE
TRANSPARENCY ACT WILL HAVE WHAT
INTO. THEY'RE DOING THE WORK
THAT I THINK WILL. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO US YES
MY WITHOUT A ROOKIE LIKE WERE
NOT NECESSARILY REQUESTING IT IN
THIS BILL FOR IT SO- THE BILL
RIGHT NOW AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT
NEEDS TO BE. ARE REAFFIRMED THE-
PIECE THAT ARE CIRCULATING AS A-
MEANS GOOD MAN. NOW THE UNITED
STATES ITS STATE. OR POSSESSIONS
INCLUDE STATE OWNED AND- SO I'M
I'M- PERSONAL I LIKE A LOT DEAR
OF THE BILL- OWNED ENTER- IS
WHERE I THINK THINGS ARE GOING
TO GET. VERY VERY TRICKY. I'VE
HAD RECOMMENDED. FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER FOLLOWING PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S. BOB LEAD ON ON THIS
ISSUE HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH
WAS ORIENTED TOWARD CHINA AND
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES THAT'S
RICH WHAT IS OF MOST INTEREST
WHEN IT COMES TO FOREIGN. TWICE
ALREADY THE STATE OWNED
ENTERPRISES THAT WAY- THE FEW NO
FOOD AG FOLKS THAT HAVE TO
COMPILE YOU KNOW WATER DATA WERE
AG DATA HAVE SOMETHING TO WORK
FROM BECAUSE UNLESS THEY HAVE
SOMETHING TO CROWD MIGHT ALLEN
CHAU FOR. THE DIVISIONS OF THE
STATE TO EVEN BEGIN THIS THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE STATE OWNED
ENTERPRISE IS A LENGTHY DATA
DRIVEN INTELLIGENCE AND SECURITY
DRIVEN PROCESS. I JUST WANT TO
THROW THAT OUT THERE THAT YOU
MAY WANT. TO CONSIDER- ENDING
THIS. BEFORE PROBES JUST TO
FOLLOW PRESIDENT BIDEN'S-
IDENTIFICATION OF THE NAMED
INDIVIDUALS. COULD BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
MISTER CHAIR AND I THINK WITH-
YOU KNOW THE WATER CRISIS THAT
WE'RE FACING NOW AND JUST AS I
WITNESSED- KIND OF TOUCHED ON
LIKE WATER THAT COULD ALSO BE
WATER RATES AND SO GUESS I
UNDERSTAND THREE- THAT. THAT
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDERS JUST
FOCUSED IN ON CHINA BUT I MEAN.
THAT WE GOT TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
IT EXACTLY- I MEAN I THINK WHEN
IT COMES THROUGH OUR MOST
NATURAL RESOURCE RIGHT NOW I
MEAN WE'RE PEOPLE ARE FACING-
WATER SHORTAGE ALL ACROSS THE
STATE RIGHT- WE NEED TO WE NEED
TO KNOW IT'S- SPONSOR. WILL IT
HAS UP ACCESS TO THIS THIS
PERSON'S NOT A RESOURCE AND ARE
IT THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF HOW YOU
KNOW THE WHOLE BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF JUST YOUR RAMIFICATIONS
THAT COME FROM IT AND AS HER
WITNESS ALSO MENTIONED- I DON'T
KNOW THERE WAS A WORK FOR BUT
VERTICAL. INTEGRATION
INTEGRATION ADDED I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S WHAT WITH WHAT WAS CALLED
I JUST CALLED THE CONSOLIDATION
BUT- IT WHAT YOU WERE SEEING A
LOT MORE OF THAT AND YES WITH
FOOD PRODUCERS AND FOOD.
PRODUCERS YES IN THE VALLEY BUT
YOU KNOW ACROSS THE NATION. AND
SO I THINK THAT. I DEFINITELY
DON'T WANT TO CREATE MORE ISSUES
RIGHT- ORGANS IT CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW MOVING THIS
THIS BILL ALONG BUT I'LL LIKE I
ALSO THINK THAT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE COULD BE A POSSIBLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THE CONCERNS. AND I'LL CONCLUDE
MY- THAT CENTER GLAZER CHURCHES
WHICH IS TO COMMENT FURTHER-
THIS IS A PROHIBITION. THIS IS A
VERY SERIOUS STEP. THIS IS
UNLIKE WHAT THE FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES HAVE. FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES BY AND LARGE HAVE
REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS WE ARE
ATTEMPTING THROUGH THIS BILL OR
YOU ARE RATHER. TO PRODUCE IT
THE FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
OWNERSHIP- DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY THROUGH STATE OWNED
ENTERPRISE OF AG RELATED ASSETS
. AND I THINK THAT IS IT THERE
IS A POSSIBILITY OF MAKING THIS
BILL WORK IN THE RIGHT WAY I
WOULD JUST STRONGLY RECOMMEND
THAT WOULD FOLLOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S LEAD ON IDENTIFYING IF
YOU DON'T WANT TO DON'T APPLY
THE COUNTRY BY NAME. ONE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE. TO RESOLVE TO
CATEGORIZE IT IN NOT AS NON
MARKET ECONOMIES. NON MARKET
ECONOMIES CAN COVER SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS OR IN THE COUNTRIES
THAT ARE REALLY AT ISSUE HERE.
WITHOUT IDENTIFYING ONE IN
PARTICULAR. GOOD FOR THOUGHT
IT'S YOUR BILL THANK THEIR
GLAZER THANK YOU CHAIR AND IT'S
GREAT TO HEAR YOUR YOUR- YOUR
BROAD SUPPORT FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND HIS- POLICIES. I
BIPARTISAN AND- AND THOUGHTFUL
OF YOU TO SAY THAT FIRST BOB
CENTER HER TADO AT THIS BILL
TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS. TO
ACCOUNT FOR CURRENT FOREIGN
OWNERSHIP AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND
IMPORT BUT OUR RECORDS A US
SECURITY INTERESTS MAY BE AT
RISK IN THIS BILL CREATES AN
IMPORTANT PAUSE- IN FOREIGN
OWNERSHIP WHILE THAT INFORMATION
IS COMPILED AND WITH THAT HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER CHAIRMAN
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
ONLY- THAT FOOTNOTE HI I'D- I
WANT TO ADD IS JUST THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU'RE
IN CONTACT WITH THE TRIBES SO
THAT WE CAN GET. I DON'T EXPECT
YOUR CONCERT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TRIBE'S OWNING
AGRICULTURAL LAND BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT THE LANGUAGE-
IS VAGUE IN REGARDS REGARD
SECOND IT JUST SAYS A FOUR AND-
A FOUR IN- I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY LIKE. IT SAYS IT'S A NON U.
S. GOVERNMENT ENTITY THEN IT YOU
KNOW IT MAY BE OVER BROAD BUT
THAT'S OTHERWISE I THINK IT'S
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT- SENATOR
GLAZERS I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT. BILL AND ON IT ABOUT
FOOD SECURITY AND SO I SUPPORT.
I WILL SUPPORT. WE HAVE A- A
MOTION ON THE BILL'S MOVE BY
CENTER GLAZER- SECONDED BY-
PRESIDENT BIDEN- WE- ALL RIGHT-
CAN WE CALL THE ROLL. SHARE I DO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR BURGESS HI FORGES AYE
HURTADO AYE HER TITLE HI
CABALLERO. CAREER HI EGGMAN
GLAZER. LASER HI. ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT- IT WILL DO A
CONSULTANT. WHY I HEARD TO HER
SHE WAS IN IT WE HAVE
CONFIRMATION. YES ON THE
CONSULTANT DIRECTION. GIVE HER A
CHANCE OKAY ALL RIGHT. THEN
WE'LL WAIT SO ON THE- WILL DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR OPEN THAT
UP FOR A CENTER TADO THEN LOSE
WEIGHT FOR CENTER EGGMAN. ON THE
SAME COUNTER ITEMS ONE TWO AND
FOUR S. B. NINE ZERO SEVEN SB
TEN TWENTY NINE IN SB FOURTEEN
NINETY NINE HER TADO I HER TITLE
BY. RIGHT THANK YOU. THE DALLAS. YOU MAY WANT TO. I THINK THIS
IS GONNA.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT- WE HAVE HEARD THAT
CENTER EGGMAN IS UNAVAILABLE
BECAUSE SHE'S PRESENTING AND
ANOTHER COMMITTEE- WITH THAT
BEING SAID HAVE WE CONCLUDED TO-
ALL MATTERS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THEN- THE
AG COMMITTEE IS DRAWING TO A
CLOSE THANK YOU.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.